not all celebrities though are like
fiddy not all celebrities like
president trump john leguizamo who's
actually quite a good actor
uh but a very annoying political
commentator john leguizamo went on the
bill maher show and he said that it
it is absolutely unacceptable for
hispanics to vote for trump
there was an article i saw in the paper
this week that talked about how
and i thought this was sort of trading
on stereotypes it said that the
trump is doing rather well with young
latino men
because of the makismo factor
and well i see you're shaking your head
is that is it bad
people for republicans are like roaches
for rape
let's just get real so
[Applause]
i i just feel like there's a level of
of self-hate or just lack of care for
the rest of your latin brothers and
sisters who are
in cages who are are being demonized by
this president i mean hate crimes
against latin people
way up and how can you not i mean 23
people were shot in el paso
for just being latin and and and you
and you don't care so you're going to go
for this braggadocio president
i i
so not much of an argument there you see
john leguizamo trying to
make several arguments but he can't
complete the thought because none of
them cohere so
he'll make one he'll say you're gonna
vote and people in cages
what do you mean latin people in cages
oh he's referring to those photos that
were going around when president trump
was enforcing our border
and it showed some people i don't know
kind of in cages or
behind at least behind metal and
what john leguizamo doesn't know is
those photos came from 2014 and those
photos
were from the obama administration
because the guy who put the
the illegal aliens in cages was barack
obama and the policy that
required this sort of behavior came from
the clinton administration
came all the way back from the 90s so
not trump's fault then he blames him
because there were shootings in
el paso trump is now responsible for el
paso doesn't make a lot of sense
what about beta or work wasn't he isn't
beta or work wasn't either
representative from el paso
no it doesn't blame him it just blames
trump there's no argument here
and what he's what he's playing into is
this oppression narrative
which was contrived in the 1970s and 80s
largely by the ford foundation actually
but by a lot of left-wing activists who
saw
the effectiveness of the black civil
rights and black power movement in the
1960s and 70s
and tried to replicate it for other
groups but the thing about this is mike
gonzalez actually
uh puts this very well in his recent
book and it's called the plot to change
america
the the kind of grievance politics only
works for black people
if it works at all it only works for
black people and specifically the
descendants of slaves
because only black people came to the
united states
on slave ships in chains against their
will all the other groups
came to the united states voluntarily
somebody's great granddaddy somebody's
ancestors down the line
chose to come to america they came here
for a purpose because it was better to
come here than to stay where they were
and so it's completely incoherent for
these you know extraordinarily
privileged great
great grandchildren like john leguizamo
a millionaire actor hollywood celebrity
to come out and say we're all so
oppressed no you're not
not only are you not oppressed now but
your ancestors weren't oppressed they
chose to come here voluntarily but they
try to do this with every single group
they're doing it now with
middle east north africa people from the
middle east have always been classified
as white in the united states
but in the past decade or so especially
during the obama administration
they tried to reclassify them as middle
east north africa linda sarsour
was behind this linda sarsour was one of
the voices behind this
and she's a radical left-wing activist
she started wearing a hijab
she was asked once why why do you wear
the hijab she said if i don't wear the
hijab
then i'm just another boring white lady
in new york
it shows you the the reality of white
privilege so-called
if there were such a thing as white
privilege then people wouldn't
be trying to disassociate
with white people and identify with a
new group called middle east north
africa
the actual privilege is to be part of an
aggrieved victimized minority
there is no privilege for being i mean
you just see this in affirmative action
right you see this
in hiring practices and college
acceptance practices
so john like was i've no one's ever
accused john leguizamo of being the most
sophisticated political philosopher in
the world
but his argument here with the with the
latinos has all of those premises behind
it and then it plays on a concept that
goes all the way back to karl marx and
it was really expanded
by what you call neo-marxists or
cultural marxists under
antonio gramsci for instance or the new
left herber marcus a lot of these
a lot of these people you saw throughout
the 20th century who were explicit
marxists working in the cultural sphere
they would describe false consciousness
the feminists
of the 1970s made this the uh
into the mainstream the the idea of a
false consciousness being
it comes it comes from these
consciousness-raising groups
that radical women would have around new
york they and women would go there and
say gosh i never knew i was oppressed
before i went to the meeting i thought i
had a nice happy life but after i left
the meeting and my consciousness was
raised the way the phrase
exists today is called raising awareness
but then it was called raising
consciousness
my consciousness was raised and now i
realize how aggrieved and victimized and
oppressed i am and that's what john
leguizamo is saying these people
they're self-hating hispanics they hate
themselves it's like a roach voting for
raid
it's they don't get it they think
they're happy and they think they love
america and they think they have a good
life
and they think their ancestors came here
for a reason but they're wrong it's
actually all
terrible it's be miserable be miserable
like me that's what he's telling them
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you